the North Korean hostages are free I
think that's good yeah
after years of imprisonment the three
hostages released by North Korea
yesterday arrived in Washington DC at 3
a.m. and were met by President Trump
yeah that's what happened
yeah something at them the hostages
laughed and said so seriously where does
the actual president it's nice to see
you but can you meet the real guy one of
the hostages said Bill Cosby did what
they've been away for a while you see a
new poll came out it reveals the
majority of Americans approve of
President Trump meeting with Kim jong-un
yeah of course the majority of Americans
also say they approve of Trump becoming
North Korea's next hostage so
they give me a cheeseburger in there and
the president's lawyer Michael Cohen is
in more trouble it's been reported that
a pharmaceutical company paid about a
million dollars to Michael Cohen yeah
Cohen has denied any connections to drug
makers saying why the very idea fills me
with dizziness dry mouth and anal
leakage it got what it should get this
is where it story last night a minor
league hockey game lasted six hours and
had five overtime periods yes yeah the
game finally ended when they ran out of
teeth so I got a little vaudevillian
there on that way yeah they ran out of
teeth in left
he dumbed the referees zing zang's only
sorry I'm off the meds hey it was
reported that in China in China the
standard work week is 9:00 a.m. to 9:00
p.m. six days a week yeah and that goes
up to seven days a week if you're a
grown up
so actually
are we doing be okay we still okay
together all right we got to get along
we're here for an hour together so you
can't turn on me now hey the FDA has
approved a drug that will make it easier
to get ready for your colonoscopy yeah
this wonder drug is known as five beers
[Applause]
that's me my you know what I'm doing
right there okay I have to know
you